(atmospheric sounds)
- [Narrator] Sword-making has always
been an esoteric endeavor.
There's never been a great
number of people doing it.
(clangs)
You have this transformation
of raw material,
the alteration of nature,
and in the end, you get something
that just exudes power.
(suspenseful music)
- [Jon Snow] This is Valyrian steel.
- [Man] My father's sword.
- [Narrator] The ancient
swords on Game of Thrones,
forged with Valyrian steel,
were stronger and lighter
than any other weapon.
No one knows how they were made.
In the real world,
over a thousand years ago in Viking lands,
there was also a series of special swords
with mysterious origins.
And a blacksmith in
Wisconsin tried to make one.
- This is an Ulfberht sword.
(metal clanking)
From about 850 to maybe early 1200s,
in Viking-controlled lands,
you had a sword that had a
name inlay called Ulfberht.
Which roughly translates to, uh,
"wolf tooth" or "wolf bear.”
It's the word of power.
(atmospheric sounds)
- [Narrator] There are only
350 known Ulfberht swords.
Forged with the quality of steel
that didn't emerge in Europe
for another thousand years
no one knows exactly how they were made.
- [Richard] I think
I've come fairly close,
or at least a pretty good rendition
of how they made those blades.
Steel is a pretty special material.
We know a great deal about it,
and we know almost nothing about it.
So with the Ulfberht, you
have a mythical steel,
mirrored in the Game of Thrones
where you have this steel that
no one's able to reproduce.
That black Valyrian steel.
Sword-making technology
still holds a bit of alchemy,
a bit of mysticism in it.
We want to believe that there's
something that we can't understand.
There's still mysteries in steel.